موسكو وبلهجه شديده ان وصلت هذه الصواريخ
اراضينا فاقراوا على انفسكم السلام وكيف
ترد لقد حان وقت الضربه الكبرى فما الذي
يجري فيما يعلن الروس موعد الهجوم على
كييف مجددا وخمسه وخمسون مليار دولار حزمه
اخرى من الدعم الاوروبي لاوكرانيا الاعلان
عن تبادل السيطره على المدن واعتراف
بالخسائر الفادحه بالحرب الاوكرانيه
وبوتين يحفز افراد جيشه بطريقه جديده فما
هي وبعد الزياره الامريكيه توجس في واشنطن
وترقب في الصين وقطر تمد ايديها بسخاء
للسودانيين واشتباكات تندلع في مستوطنه
اسرائيليه وتل ابيب تعلن الخسائر
الحرب تشتعل من جديد
الكر والفر يعود من جديد وهكذا هي عاده
الحروب يا ساده ضربه بضربه والفائز يضحك
اخيرا وبعد ان كانت اوكرانيا قد اعلنت
استعاده ثمن قريه من القوات الروسيه
بالقرب من ساحل بحر ازوف الهجوم المضاد
المستمر منذ اسبوعين خرجت مسؤوله كبيره
بوزاره الدفاع لتتعهد بضربه كبرى في
الايام المقبله رغم المقاومه الشديده التي
تبديها موسكو لكن عن اي ضربه كبرى تتحدث
كياف لياتي الرد من وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
باعلان سيطره قواتها بشكل كامل على مدينه
وقالت وزاره الدفاع ان القوات الروسيه صدت
هجوم اوكرانيا ودمرت نحو 50 اليه ودبابه
اوكرانيه خلال القتال وها هو المصدر
كعادتنا القوات الروسيه تعلن ان سيطرت على
بلده نوفو دونيسك في مقاطعه دوناتس وتعلن
ايضا استمرار صدرها الهجمات الاوكرانيه
هناك ازداد الغضب الروسي لتقوله هيئه
الاركان العامه للقوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه
ان القوات الروسيه شنت هجوما جويا واسعا
بالمسيرات خلال الساعات الماضيه على
البلاد مستهدفه العاصمه
ان القوات الاوكرانيه تصدت للهجوم واسقطت
الدفاعاتها الجويه ثمانيا
فما كل هذه الهجمات وما كل تلك التصديات
برايكم هل الارقام المعلنه حقيقيه لذلك
هيا لنشاهد المصدر قالت هيئه للاركان
العامه للقوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه قولها
ان القوات الروسيه شنت هجوما جويا واسعا
خلال ساعه الماضيه على البلاد مستهدفه
العاصمه كييف ومدن في شرقي البلاد وغربها
وقالت الهيئه ان القوات الاوكرانيه تتصدت
للهجوم الذي استخدمت فيه خمس وثلاثون
مسيره ايرانيه الصنع من نوع شاهد مشيره
الى ان الدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه اسقطت
32 مسيره كانت معظمها يحاول استهداف
العاصمه كياف فيما اعلنت دائره حرس الحدود
الاوكرانيه عن تدمير قواتها بالمدفعيه
لمخزن ذخيره تابعه للقوات الروسيه بالقرب
من بخمه شرق البلاد وهنا تحتدم المعارك
اكثر من جهته قال الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن ان تهديد الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين باستخدام اسلحه نوويه تكتيكيه حقيقي
وهي رساله من بيض للغرب ان بوتا لا يلعب
واذا ارادوا استخداما نووي فسيفعل فماذا
انتم فاعلون ايها الغربيون الاجابه جاءت
من وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انطوني بلينكل
بقوله بانه يجب دعم اوكرانيا كي تنجح في
الانضمام الى الاتحاد الاوروبي مؤكدا خلال
مؤتمر الصحفي في لندن مع نظيره البريطاني
انا واشنطن ستقدم حز مه مساعدات عسكريه
جديده الى اوكرانيا ولكن ويا للاسف فقد
حصلت اوكرانيا على اسلحه ومعدات بمليارات
الدولارات بالاضافه الى تدريبات مكثفه
لالاف الجنود استعدادا لهجوم لتحرير
الاراضي الاوكرانيه من سيطره القوات
الروسيه لكن الهجمات الاوليه دفعت
الاوكران للتوقف عن التقدم لاعاده تقييم
التكتيكات لان الهجمات بطيئه ومميته
ومكلفه وفقا
ليخرج قائد قوات احمد الخاصه الشيشانيه
ابكي على معبرا عن اعتقاده بان الهجوم
الاوكراني المضاد قد يستمر لمده شهر ونصف
الشهر ثم سيتم على الارجح تقدم قواتنا
بشكل تدريجي في اتجاه كياف وفق قوله ليوصل
الروس والاوكرانيا وهجماتهم اعلنت ان
الجيش الاوكراني وصل محاولاته الفاشله
للهجوم على محاور جنوب دونتسك
والزابوريجيا
مؤكده مقتل امام مجموعه
645 جنديا معاديا خلال اليوم الماضي رقم
كبير ومخيف ولكن اطمئنوا فلدينا المصدر
هيا لنتابع وهنا افاد حاكم مقاطعه الروسيه
بان الجيش الاوكراني قصف اراضي المقاطعه
باكثر من 120 قذيفه خلال اليوم الماضي
مضيفا ان القصف لم يؤدي الى وقوع اصابات
ليعلنها وزير الدفاع الروسي
تخطط الاستهداف شبه جزيره القرم بصواريخه
سترد على ذلك بضرب مراكز صنع القرار في
اوكرانيا فورا فهل يقصد انه سيستهدف
الحكومه الاوكرانيه والرئيسه شخصيا الوقت
كفيل بالاجابه على هذا السؤال دعونا نكمل
وبعد الخسائر الفادعه في اوكرانيا افادت
وكاله بلومبر بان الاتحاد الاوروبي يعد
حزمه مساعدات ماليه لاوكرانيا تبلغ حوالي
50 مليار يورو او 55 مليار دولار وذلك
لتمويل النفقات الحاليه للحكومه
الاوكرانيه ودفع تكلفه اولويات اعاده
الاعمار العاجل وهذه الارقام لم ناتي بها
نحن كالعاده فها انتم ترون المصدر اوروبا
بصدد تقديم 55 مليار دولار مساعدات اضافيه
لاوكرانيا
وبما ان اوروبا تتحدث عن المبالغ الماليه
هنا جاء الدور على الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين ولكن بوتين لا يقدم امواله الا لمن
يستحقها كما يقول
لتمنح وزاره الدفاع الروسيه جنديا نجح في
تدمير دبابه ليوبارد الالمانيه مكافاه
ماليه بلغت مليون روبل وذلك ضمن خطه روسيه
لتحفيز الجنود في ميادين المعارك وتكريمهم
بشكل متواصل وكان بوتين يقول اذا كان هناك
من يستحق الدعم والمكافات فهم هؤلاء
الجنود
الاحداث والتطورات
بعد ان اختتم وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
انطوني بلينكن زيارته الى الصين ليؤكد انه
اتفق مع القياده الصينيه على الحاجه الى
استقرار العلاقات الثنائيه بين البلدين في
المقابل عبر الرئيس الصيني عن امله في ان
تساهم هذه الزياره ايجابيا في تعزيز
العلاقات على اساس الاحترام المتبادل
بينما عبر الرئيس الامريكي عن اعتقاده بان
العلاقات بين امريكا والصين تنظيف الطريق
الصحيح لكنه قال انه لا يعتقد بان زياره
وزير الخارجيه انطوني بلينكل الى الصين
احرز التقدما يبدو ان واشنطن ادركت ان لغه
القوه لا تجدي مع التنين الاحمر ليردخ
الامريكانو الى لغه التفاوض وقعت شركه قطر
للطاقه اتفاقيه لمض الصيني باربع ملايين
طن مطري من الغاز المسال لمده 27 عاما
ولذلك بحسب ما نشرته وكاله الانباء
القطريه فيما اعلن رئيس مجلس الوزراء وزير
الخارجيه القطري الشيخ محمد بن عبد الرحمن
الثاني تعهد قطر بتقديم 50 مليون دولار
لدعم خطه الاستجابه الطارئه في السودان
اطلاق نهر واشتباكات في مستوطنه عيلي شمال
مدينه رام الله بالضفه الغربيه وصافرات
الانذار تدوي في المنطقه لتندلع مخاوف
اسرائيليه من تسلل مسلحين فلسطينيين الى
المستوطنه وهناك تم الاعلان عن سقوط اربع
قتلى واربع جرحى بينما تم تحييد المهاجم
كما اعلنت هيئه الاركان الاسرائيليه ليعلن
وزير الدفاع تل ابيب مع رئيس الاركان
ورئيس الشابات ان كل الخيارات مطروحه فما
الذي يجري للاسرائيليين تهجم وموسكوترد
بهجوم اخر ومع كثافه كل تلك الهجمات
وارتفاع الخسائر كثيرا اما ان للطرفين ان
يجنوا حال السلام
[موسيقى]